ابرق ارعد ابطالا وعدوك انبل وعد جاءوك
بصوت الحق الهادر كازيم الرعد
انا اعتذر فصوتي ليس جيدا للغناء لكن هيك
لا تستغربوا ان اخبرتكم من هذا المسلسل
سيكون جزءا من حاضرنا الاهداف الفضائيه
اصبحت من الماضي بعد ان اصبح الخيال حقيقه
بوجود هذه الطائره السلاح الذي سيعطل
الاقمار الصناعيه للولايات المتحده بل
وسيدمرها في الارض او في الفضاء سلاح
سيجعل الليت في خطر يا ساده روسيا تصنع
مقاتله تجعل الاقمار الصناعيه عمياء
وتائها انها طائره الفضاء الروسيه طائره
فرط صوتيه اسرع حتى من الصواريخ الطائره
التي حيرت العالم برمته قدرتها على مرعبه
امام اقوى انظمه الرادار تصطاد الاهداف
الفضائيه ولا تخطئ اهدافها الطائره الفضاء
الروسيه ميغفورت ونتحدث وللقصه بقيه
[موسيقى]
تاخرت روسيا كثيرا في انتاج مقاتلات الجيل
الخامس مقارنه بامريكا لكن الامر لن يكون
كذلك بالنسبه للجيل السادس فالجيل الخامس
سيعفوا عليها الزمن بعد حين فورا اتجهت
موسكو لشركه
المصنعه للمقاتله
الروس يريدون تطويرها وعن اي تطوير نتحدث
مقاتله اعتراضيه سرعتها 3 ما اخذ تحلق على
ارتفاعات عاليه ومع ذلك قامت
باول رحله له في عام
1981 لتبدا الشركه الروسيه العمل على
مشروع طائره مقاتله جديده عام 2017 خرج
القائد السابق للقوات الجويه الروسيه
فيكتور بونداريف متباهيا ليقول
مقاتله في العالم وستقدر على اعتراض اهداف
فرط صوتيه وهي طائره شبحيه قادره على
اخفاء نفسها عن الرادارات المضاده ويمكن
تحويلها الى طائره مسيره وماذا بعد يا هذا
ماذا تركت للدول الاخرى لتصنعه قادره على
التعامل مع القادمين من كواكب اخرى طائره
القيصر الروسي بوتين المنتظره استاثرت
باهتمام الاعلام الاجنبي
الخفيه المتطوره مقاتله اعتراضيه بسرعه
عاليه جدا تبلغ 4 الى 4.3 اي اربعه امثال
سرعه الصوت انها فرط صوتي وليس الطائره
قدرات خارقه لمقاتله الجيل السادس وفوق كل
ذلك مواصفات فضائيه تمكنها من التعامل مع
القادمين من كواكب اخرى هل هذه حقيقه ام
خيال ما هذا الذي اقوله اذا لابد من حضور
بعض المصادر اليكم المصدر الاول صحيفه
العالميه لتين اعتمدنا عليهما في انشاء
هذا الفيديو بالاضافه الى مصادر اخرى من
فوت 1 الروسيه ستتسلح بصواريخ كنجا حتى ان
وسائط الدفاع الجوي المتوفره في العالم لا
تستطيع ايقاف هذه الصواريخ
اسرع طائره في العالم
يعمل الدب الروسي على تطوير هذه المقاتله
منذ عام 2013 ويتم تنفيذ جميع الاعمال في
جو من السريه التامه الا من بعض المعلومات
التي خرجت سهوا عن موسكو والصين
لتستلقيفها المخابرات الامريكيه بكل شغب
وهناك شيء واحد فقط يقال بثقه تامه هذه
الطائره من الجيل السادس هي واحده من
الطائرات التي ستحل محل طائره
التي تم تشغيلها لاول مره قبل اربعين عاما
تقريبا تصميم ميغ فوت 1 لاداء مهام قتاليه
معقده في درجات حراره منخفضه في القطب
الشمالي وفي ظروف قاسيه بالقرب من الفضاء
ستكون الطائره قادره على اسقاط صواريخ
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت وكذلك مواجهه
الطائرات
من الصوت بفعاليه يمكن ان تصل سرعه الى 4
ماخخ اي نحو خمسه الاف كيلو متر في الساعه
ما يجعلها اسرع طائره في العالم في حين
تصل سرعه الى اثنين فاصله
ولكن هذا يكفي الاعتراض قاذفات العدو
والصواريخ كروم وبذلك تصبح المقاتله
تجسيدا حيا لكلمه السرعه مزوده بتقنيات
التخف المتقدمه ومسلحه بجميع انواع
الصواريخ الروسيه الحديثه بما في ذلك
النظام الصاروخي الاسرع من الصوت
مهلا مهلا فتسليحها لم ينتهي بعد ويضاف
لترسانه اسلحتها صواريخ
سفن قادره على ضرب الاهداف على مسافه تصل
الى ثلاثمائه يتم استبدالها بعد بعض الوقت
بصواريخ
kc.
بمدى يصل الى 400 كيلومتر وكل هذا يسمح
لروسيا بالحصول على مقاتله من الطراز
السادس ليس لها نظائر في العالم
اطلاقوا اقمار صناعيه الى المدار
بالفوت 1 ان تعمل في الفضاء وحسبه بل
ستزود المقاتله باحدث الاجهزه الالكترونيه
او اي مرحلي في حين ستعمل الصواريخها في
الفضاء ستكون قادره على اسقاط اقمار العدو
او على العكس من ذلك اطلاق اقمارها
الصناعيه صغيره الحجم الى المدار بمساعده
الصواريخ حتى نكثه كانت تستخدم لذلك نجف
واحده من اهم المشاريع المغلقه من صناعه
الدفاع الروسيه الحديثه وستكون بمثابه
طائره واحده معقده مناوره في الفضاء
واعتراضيه لكن القدره على المناوره لا
تعتبر امرا بالغ الاهميه بالنسبه لمقاتله
الاعتراض المزوده بصواريخ فرض صوتيه
والاهم بالنسبه له والارتفاع الذي قد يبلغ
100 متر اي حدود الفضاء مع قدره فائقه على
القيام بدوريات طويله الامد والتعامل مع
كافه انواع الاهداف بما فيها الصواريخ
المجنحه الصغيره الحجم والمروحيات
والطائرات فوق الصوتيه المحلقه على
ارتفاعات عاليه وذلك ليلا ونهارا وفي
الظروف الجويه المعقده وعلى خلفيه التشويش
المعادي المكثف فقد تم تزويدها بمنظومه
مراقبه حديثه ذات شاشه كبيره لعرض
المعلومات التي تمكن الطياره من الاطلاع
على الوضع الجوي للمعركه وتحديد
الاحداثيات والملاحه بواسطه الاقمار
الاصطناعيه وبهذا تقول روسيا لطائرات
الولايات المتحده وانظمه دفاعها الجوي كوش
ملك
ستطير بسهوله فوق الاراضي الامريكيه دون
ان تتعرض للاصابه من قبل ايه دروع جويه او
يصرخ الامريكان هناك بكل ما اوتوا من قوه
روسيا طورت اسلحه يمكن ان تعطل اقمارنا
الصناعيه او تدمرها من الارض او في الفضاء
او في الفضاء الالكتروني يا اثقل الطائره
المخصصه لخوض العمليات الحربيه في الجو
واسرعها قادره على تبادل المعلومات مع
الرادارات الارضيه والطائرات الانذار
الراداري المبكر لاعتراض الطائرات الشبحيه
المعاديه على مسافه مئات الكيلومترات لكن
دورها الاستراتيجي وانكانتها في مجال خوض
الحرب الفضائيه سيشكل اكبر خطوره على
الطائرات والاقمار الصناعيه التابعه
برايكم هل تعتبر ميغ فوت 1 هي الطائره
الاقوى والاسرع في العالم المصادر صحيفه
سوغو الصينيه مجله ناشونال مجله لونت
دبلوماتيكو صحيفه
[موسيقى]